die lehrer sagen du interessiert ich
will nicht mehr isoliert sich von den
anderen
wieso findet ihr euch so oft will man
sich das ist alles noch was anderes
kommt nicht oft vor dass man sagen kann
einen film schlägt eine neue seite im
kino auf aber hier ist es doch der fall
und zwar ist das besondere an diesem
film mit 17 von andré téchiné eigentlich
nicht liebesgeschichte zweier jungen die
in so einer art virale wechselspiel
zwischen gewalt und begehren hin und her
dass weniger diese geschichte die so
besonders wirkt an diesem film als die
selbstverständlichkeit mit der das alles
erzählt das ist von meiner mutter ich
meine verhärtet
aber nach und von drei tigern spielt die
mutter eines der jungen und vielleicht
ist sie wirklich der große star des
films weil auch wirtschaft die balance
zu halten zwischen den mütterlichen
gefühlen zu ihrem sohn der sich ein
anderes kind einen jungen verliebt hat
und den der zweideutigkeit der gefühle
die sie wiederum mit den jungen
verbinden als ganzen haus gesagt dass er
später bezahlen lassen nein ganz schön
wird ich kann es auch leicht wird was
auch an diesem film ganz besonders
zauberhaft wirkt ist die landschaft die
art und weise wie er die landschaften
die jahreszeiten in seiner erzählung mit
einbezieht der ist ja etwas was uns im
deutschen kino oft fehlt und hier im
verglichen kino ist er noch ganz gar
nicht selbstverständlich da auf eine für
mich immer wieder bewundernswert und
überraschende weise
[Musik]
hier ist ein film der von homosexuelle
liebe ohne jede art besonderer betonung
mit einer art gefasst gleichen gut
möchte man sagen erzählt die die in
besonderen charme hat einen besonderen
zauber